NARRATOR: In the high cliffs
of Alaska's Kodiak Island--
That's pretty exciting.
NARRATOR: --the world's
largest brown bears--
Probably doing
the first day out.
NARRATOR: --are
back on the prowl.
That's the only one I see.
He's just working
his way up the hill.
He's not really
necessarily eating,
he's just kind of traveling.
Might be going from one
green spot to another.
Honey, you see him?
[dog whimpers]
The bear's not necessarily
a very big bear,
but it's encouraging
just that I found a bear.
You could go for
10 days, 15 days.
There's no set pace for it.
It can happen at any time.
Hopefully, we're gonna
see a lot of bears.
Even though we're gonna
have to pick through them
to determine which is
trophy quality or not,
there's a lot of bears
that you're gonna see,
young bears that
are gonna be rubbed.
There won't even be
enough hair on them
to make a toilet seat cover.
But as many years as
I've been doing this,
I can recognize them for
what they are, and take
them one bear at a time.
Come on.
NARRATOR: The hunt
begins in six weeks.
Until then, all Mike
can do is keep watch.
MIKE: I came here because,
traditionally, it's
been a good spot in years past.
NARRATOR: Map out a strategy.
MIKE: And now that
I've seen a bear,
I'm gonna utilize this place.
NARRATOR: And prepare to
survive among the deadliest
predators in the wild.
[music playing]
I'm gonna stash a tent.
If I end up coming
out of here real late,
or if there's a real bad
storm and I get stuck here,
I'll have a tent, and we'll have
shelter and a place to stay.
I'm gonna stash
it up in the tree.
Otherwise, I'm
afraid if I set it
up that another bear
could come along
and use it for a chew toy.
Every season we have to do this.
Everything I can get
done without having
to do it when the
hunters with me
are just one step
ahead of the game.
[music playing]
I feel real good about
seeing a bear today already.
We've got good weather coming.
A lot of snow is already gone.
Things are turning green.
I think it's gonna be great.
That's the first
one of the season,
but I'm sure we'll
be seeing more.
[music playing]